for some reason people are upset this
has like been one of the bigger topics I
mean Roby arguing about it maybe a
little yummy and ripped me and Rogan
were arguing about it about Bruce Lee
how they put he was portrayed and once
upon a time in Hollywood hear me I'll be
you chime in on this too I haven't seen
the flick yet so I okay well yeah you
haven't seen either wellness yeah so
here's what I was saying to Rogen I said
I went how about that Bruce Lee scene it
was awesome I'm gonna describe the scene
if you have seen it spoiler alert in
three two one
suck my balls so the thing is is in the
movie Brad Pitt is like a he's a
stuntman but he's a tough stuff man who
can fight and they're on a set of this
Western Bruce Lee's they're like showing
the people how to fight and Bruce Lee
says something like oh I could kill that
guy in one [ __ ] punch and Brad Pitt
starts laughing and then Bruce Lee is
like what the [ __ ] you laughing at he's
like that come on that's not true and as
you want to try it and then get a fight
and Brad Pitt based he's like he does
his signature like flying dragon kick
and Brad Pitt's character beats the [ __ ]
like take some beat to that and they
make him seem kind of like stupid like
gimmicky like wow I trying I loved it
cuz this because you're like
over-seasoned about to beat the [ __ ]
that's right
Quinn Tarantino might well know everyone
has that manager let's do this so to me
it's a movie it's entertainer also Bruce
Lee has no real record of being in real
character so that's exactly how we go
down thank you yes thank that's exec I
would probably go down and probably from
wrestling in Oklahoma or boxing whatever
it is I know some tape Fletcher tyron
woodley stunt stuff it beat the [ __ ]
[ __ ] I've yeah but that like
contemporary pro MMA guys with the
progression of the mixed martial arts
but I'm just saying it like Bruce Lee
like what he did for martial arts is
amazing man amazing didn't have no life
or business plan brought it over here
with it with everything and grew the
sport and mixed MMA I don't know if he'd
even come around for was it for him
that's all fine and dandy when it comes
to real fighting we don't know but we
have heard things on Hollywood sets when
the people are like well no he was an
actor yeah - oh we do know he was he
never had any fights and we see you
watch how he fights in those movies he's
doing stuff that would not work in it's
not
real in real but that's why I loved it
I'm telling you I almost still am i
cheering clap because I went all Bruce
is gonna beat the [ __ ] a Brad Penny
watch like that's exactly I would go
down right if if what people are
thinking and I loved it yeah Brodie
something Logan do you like it myself
120 just cuz you want to preserve the
image per se or yeah well he's saying
it's [ __ ] up cuz it makes him look
kind of stupid and I arrogant yeah yeah
like what he's not supposed to be I
guess and this buyers I think we don't
know oh yes so there's a guy named
Matthew Pauly who's supposed to be a
biographer of Bruce Lee and says he has
like some knowledge whether it's like
through other people or whatever that he
did get into fights and then beat him up
on set but that challenge referre I know
so there's no real proof if Bruce Lee
tried to fight that's nothing they said
would never do that he would never let
me show you how the Muhammad Ali Bruce
Lee if I would go let me know Bruce Lee
I'm a pepper Muhammed Lee cool no no so
they're saying in that movie that Bruce
Lee said that he would beat up Muhammad
Ali like when usually a himself would
never say something like that so they
didn't like them saying that about
measly but here's the other thing
Hollywood it's also fiction Bruce Lee
[ __ ] they love him dude he it's a
movie that was crazy
so it's a quintero Quentin Tarantino
movie yeah it's not based on everybody
calm down and yes Mario Robbie didn't
speak a lot everybody calm down it's a
[ __ ] great that's a great movie also
the ending the twist no well that's not
it's not good the Kill Bill thing or
whatever
I loved it man but everyone's just
trying to write that the world's full of
hate now so it's like well let's
complain about this this was like the he
was a great it's a great entertainer and
he was a pioneer and he brought martial
arts to the mainstream and he was
incredible it doesn't mean he was a
fighter it means he was a great powerful
personality one of the great
personalities in the twentieth century
at least in American culture there's no
question and impact was incredible
there's also something that I read that
Brad Pitt himself didn't want that scene
to go that way where that seemed like he
would win shut you like you read
I shut you but notice Lee was also a guy
who brought probably gave a lot of
respect to Asian Americans where people
like you know especially during that
time yeah like he made it like was cool
to be Asian yeah still is pretty cool he
said I'm getting better being I'm not
I'm not I'm saying yeah you do have more
American or Chinese because I feel human
yeah it's like a him no again
bro I just quoted Bruce Lee and I don't
even know it well he was a great
philosopher that's the key I did do
Bruce Lee drop completely drop knowledge
man yeah that's one they you can't take
that away from all I'm saying is in the
world I he lived in Hollywood in a real
fight that's a real guy who knows what
the [ __ ] he's doing that's exactly how I
probably would've went Dennis
sorry Bruce Lee not huggers that's right
brother what else not pants oh you what
do you think chin I feel like you want
to say son bro no I don't know I don't
know Ronnie Lee bro today bro I'm
prickly did you all good yeah I think
Bruce Lee could beat up Jon Jones I'm
that's fair
what else yeah gen-pop Ruben so here I
only can prove it right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]